so right over here we have the graph of
y is equal to one over x squared and my
question to you is what is the limit of
1 over x squared as X approaches zero
pause this video and see if you can
figure that out well when you try to
figure it out you immediately see
something interesting happening at x
equals zero the closer we get to zero
from the left you take 1 over x squared
it just gets larger and larger and
larger it doesn't approach some finite
value it's unbounded has no bound and
the same thing is happening as we
approach from the right as we get values
closer and closer to zero from the right
we get larger and larger values for 1
over x squared without bound
so terminology that folks will sometimes
use where they're both going in the same
direction but it's unbounded as they'll
say this limit is unbounded in some
context you might hear teachers say that
this limit does not exist or and it
definitely does not exist if you're
thinking about approaching a finite
value in future videos we'll start to
introduce ideas of infinity and
notations around limits and infinity
where we can get a little bit more
specific about what type of limit this
is but with that out of the way let's
look at another scenario this right over
here you might recognize as the graph of
y is equal to 1 over X so I'm going to
ask you the same question pause this
video and think about what's the limit
of 1 over X as X approaches 0 pause this
video and figure it out alright so here
would we approach from the left we get
more and more and more negative values
while we when we approach from the right
we're getting more and more positive
values so in this situation where we're
not getting unbounded in the same
direction the previous example we were
both we were being unbounded in the
positive direction but here on though
from the left we're getting unbounded in
the negative direction while from the
right we're getting unbounded in the
positive direction and so when you're
thinking about the limit as you approach
a point if it's not even approaching the
same value or even the same direction
you would just clearly say that this
limit does not exist does
not exist so this is a situation where
you would not even say that this is an
unbounded limit or that the limit is
unbounded because you're going in two
different directions when you're
approached from the right and when you
approach from the left you would just
clearly say does not exist